Earlier in the course you found out
that there aren't enough addresses to go
around.
There are actually fewer IPv4 addresses
than there are people in the world, and
some of us use way
more than one address.
I mean, every sensible person
carries five computers with
them at all times, right?
The major workaround has been for
ISPs to assign only one address to each
household, office, or other customer.
And if you had a one computer household,
it would obvious how this would work.
One host, one IP address.
But as people have lots of different
computers and devices in their house
today, they all have to hide behind
this one IP address and from
the outside world have to look just like
a single machine with a single address.
Well, how does this work?
Let's take the example
of a home network.
Maybe they've got a desktop computer,
and a laptop, and a smart TV, and
some phones, and all of these talk
to the internet through a router,
which acts as their default gateway.
The router connects to their ISP and
gets a single real public IP address,
and then it assigns private
addresses to all of these devices.
Private IP addresses come off of one
of three reserved IP address netblocks.
The most common private IP addresses
found on home routers are in the network
192.168.0.0/24.
With the default gateway of 192.168.0.1,
this is only one of very many
private IP address possibilities.
If you ever need to look these up,
they're specified in an internet
standard called RFC 1918.
Private IP addresses are used
with a system called NAT or
network address translation.
The way that it works is that whenever
traffic goes between the private network
behind the router and the public
internet, the router has to rewrite or
translate to the network
addresses on it.
The router maintains a map of
which inside addresses and
ports are connected to what public
internet addresses and ports.
Now most likely your own home or
office network is using NAT, but
NAT is really a workaround not
a solution to address shortage.
It creates some pretty serious problems.
It makes it much harder,
sometimes impossible,
for end users to run servers
that other people can access.
That makes it hard to write and
debug network applications that
are going to run on end user machines.
The router has to keep track of all
the connections going through it, and
because your computer doesn't
know it's real public address,
applications on it can't easily say
things like forward all my internet
phone calls to this address without
hacky extra protocol arrangements.
And more moving parts makes
them more error prone.